je t'aime mon peter tué un garçon
extraordinaire plus que tu ne peux
l'imaginer je te promets que tu me
reverra dans ce monde
on a notre
c'est
ouais
c'était qui
est ce que c'est le canada c'est le
pirate que tous les tirades creil
du brave [ __ ] autant que je peux
l'être
mais james crochet j'essaie de te sauver
la vie petit pourquoi laisse moi faire
gente demoiselle nous venons en paix mon
petit robe de la flûte et le guerrier le
plus grave de notre tribu il était écrit
4 en retour on combattre ensemble les
pirates
si barbe noire menace de tout détruire
tu me dresserait contre lui à genoux je
ne plierai jamais devant vous
en avant tout
l'ancien prophétie évoque un jeune
garçon
garçon qui aurait disparu de ce monde
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit en âge de revenir
huawei
c'est de mener la révolte contre moi
garçon qui pourrait relais
allez petit il faut visite croire
je crois je crois
le lagon des sirènes je pense qu'elles
vont plaire tu l'as dit petit